To deal with rainwater and heat,...
...Berlin is being transformed into what's being called a Sponge City.
Carlo Becker is the architect of Berlin's Sponge City strategy,...
...which harnesses rainwater and manages heat.
In a natural ecosystem, rainwater is soaked up by soil and vegetation.
The majority then evaporates and the rest filters deeper into the ground.
The evaporating water then cools the surroundings.
Cities disrupt this system.
Water can't soak through the concrete and is piped away.
The Sponge City strategy aims to keep rainwater where it lands,..
...to imitate the natural water cycle.
Buildings are covered in green roofs and facades.
And down on street-level, urban wetlands...
...and roadside trenches known as Swales filter runoff and hold water,...
...keeping the city cool by imitating nature.